Speaker 1: All right, let's hear for a
few from a few more people via discord,
you can find our discord at David Pakman
dotcom slash discord. Let's start off with
Alphie from London. You're on the air.
Speaker 3: Oh, hey, David. I just had
a quick question. I'm not sure if this is
something you've really talked about before.
Mainly just sort of what your opinion is
on euthanasia and the sort of right to
the right to death in medical circumstances.
Speaker 1: I tend to be I tend to be pro
right to decide you don't want to
live anymore. And I do think that,
you know, because. There can always be bad actors
in any system, no matter what safeguards we have,
I think we do want to put in place a system
that would make it, if not impossible,
really difficult for either bad actor physicians
or bad actor family members or whatever to get
involved in ways that could be really bad. But
I've generally been supportive of euthanasia laws.
Speaker 3: OK, yeah, it's weird. Whenever
I ask someone about this, they tend to have
some sort of variation on that. This seem
like vaguely supporters, but it just seems
weird in the UK and a lot of places in America
it's like entirely legal. Yeah. So I wonder if
you think that will go anywhere any soon.
Speaker 1: It doesn't feel, at least at
the federal level like this is a big issue,
but it doesn't necessarily need to be a big
issue at the federal level because many of these
decisions in the US are made at the state level.
So I think it will really depend on
state level activists if they want to
do more to try to move forward in certain states
on it. But it's not feeling right like right now
in taking the pulse of the country, that it's a
massive issue of the people that care about it,
care about it a lot. I don't mean that there
aren't people who are very passionate about it,
but it doesn't feel like it's the biggest
issue or anywhere close to it right now.
Speaker 3: Yeah, definitely. OK,
fair enough. Yeah, that was it.
Thanks very much for taking my call.
Speaker 1: All right. Thanks very much.
That's Alphie from London getting
getting right to it, which I love.